tell me if i'm wrong
what like tell me what happened with the
running back in football because
they went from being the running back
was the most popular player when i was
growing up
we there's barry sanders and emmitt
smith and you know
uh terrell davis and all these guys were
the guys who
almost like when you would play madden
you would pick the best running back
team you know what i mean because
and somehow i feel like the nfl has made
running backs
very disposable it's like
you know it feels like they're the last
guys to get paid when it's time when
it's time
time comes up for them to get a contract
usually they'll it's that running back
by committee's a thing now what do you
think happened with the position that
because back then when when you got
drafted it was
they expected you to carry the offense
yeah you know
i think it's a couple of things and you
know my theory is the first thing is i
think the nature of coaches changed
okay i think when you had the old school
like you know vince lombardi style the
coach like ditka
right there play defense and run the
ball right very conservative
smash mouth football and then you
started having you know these
intellectual
smart coaches like the guy arizona right
and so they start scheming right and
this morning's better yeah and it's more
fun to scheme a passing game and throw
in the
it's more exciting right to scheme a
passing game and throwing and throwing
the ball around
than it is to scheme a run game and turn
it and then hand the ball out right
that's part of it the other part is
running backs especially the old way
you know we took a pounding and it just
you couldn't depend on a running back
you can't even think of like like
when you said you had the balls carried
about 400 times and so it's it's
yeah you can't even think about it yeah
so so that doesn't last long
and also i think running backs even
though i think it's the most skilled
position because you have to be able to
do a lot of different things
it's pretty easy to get to get running
backs and i think they learn you have to
move them through because you can't just
depend on one guy for too long
especially now with this
this these fast offenses uh and also i
think at receiver
you know receiver has a good game you
know that's 10 an amazing game is 10
you know 10 touches right you've touched
the ball [ __ ] 32 exactly
exactly and sometimes receivers will
catch the ball and go out of bounds and
so
you can have a star receiver and pay him
a lot of money and be
feel confident he's going to stay
healthy but at a running back you give
him a lot of money he's taking a pound
you don't know well you did a good job
of of
like i said i feel like some people
might have counted you out and then when
you came back
you you were murdering [ __ ] so you did a
good job of like extending your peak i
guess right yeah
nowadays we'll see someone like you know
um
someone like i'm trying to think um
i feel like we you know we we saw it a
little bit with zeke this year
but you'll see somebody who is like
david johnson let's use a guy on the
cardinals right
david johnson i just remember had like
the crazy season he had some injuries
but when he came back it should
i feel like the drop off for running
backs is quick and fast
like why do you think that is now like
what do you notice because you did a
good job of exp
i feel like you came from the days where
like most running backs had like nine
ten-year you know we think emma smith
yeah and
and jerome bettis yeah now peterson
ap now we see [ __ ] and they're
they're in and out they got three four
years they get a contract and usually
it's like you always hear the people
always criticize nfl
teams when they give the running back
the fat contract yeah because like have
you not learned
yeah yeah yeah but that's what i'm
saying because running back is such a
difficult position because
you know that if you're carrying the
load every there's a target on you
you're going to get hit a lot
right i think you know when you're
hungry and trying to get that check
it's easier but once you get paid it's
it's human nature
who reminds you of uh the way you used
to play now
um uh fournette leonard fournette
hey i was so happy to see him in the
super bowl he looks like he really did
good too
dirty in jacksonville he looked so good
but it was a wake-up call for him and he
and he responded he looked he looked
really good i was
i was impressed